IN IRISH ACCENT: Now we're in
trouble. This is your fault.
It is not. Get yourself on,
you put lipstick on the baby Jesus.
He was looking a bit pale.
And you stole from Sister Michael,
I'm gonna be in trouble
with my mammy.
What did you steal? Tweezers.
Nice beard, Sister Michael.
Have you done what I've told ya?
TOGETHER: No.
Start the show.
TOGETHER: Welcome to the
Great Festive Bake Off, so it is.
What's her problem?
Why's she not talking?
She's South African,
she can't do the accent.
Today...
Get it!
..the cast of the Derry Girls...
Oh! ..take over the tent...
What on Earth's going on over there?
..tackling a trifling Signature...
Let's make some custard, ooh.
..serving up some
canapes in the Technical...
Mine just look like
disappointing Iced Gems.
..and a Showstopper... Argh!
..that goes back in time.
1930s Cabaret.
Who will rise to the challenge...
Me and Prue are like...
..and be crowned the
first Star Baker...
Happy New Year. ..of 2020?
Woo!
I wanna go home.
To celebrate the start of
a new year, it's a Bake Off first,
as the cast of the hit sitcom, Derry
Girls, have descended on the tent.
What? I knew it.
When I woke up this morning, I had a
feeling something terrible was gonna
happen and also that, essentially,
deep down, I'm quite an evil person.
It's called a hangover, Clare,
you'll be grand.
I will be taking this class
for the rest of the term,
which makes me want to pull off
my own face, but needs must.
The Derry Girls set is such
a happy place to work on.
Everybody, cast, crew,
we all have such a lovely time.
But that doesn't mean
that I won't crush them.
I wanna win.
I don't even know what I'm gonna win
if I win - just glory and power -
and then, that I'm the queen of
baking, which, I assume,
is the title
that you get when you win.
I'm a huge fan of Bake Off.
I'd normally be spending
New Year's Day, if I wasn't here,
horrifically hungover and
I can't decide,
with the fear, which one's worse.
Green aprons. Do you think
it's green cos we're Irish?
I have done no practice.
Uh, should I...? I mean,
I've done a lot of practice -
should I say I've done
a lot of practice?
Do you want me to tighten
that for you? Thanks.
Got it.
I'm pretty nervous to
bake for Prue and Paul,
but, at the same, time I'm like
let's have it, come on, like, yeah.
SIOBHAN: Don't mess it up, guys.
I've got a cookery book coming out.
Happy New Year, bakers,
and welcome to some festive fun
in the Bake Off tent.
Today, for your Signature
Challenge,
Paul and Prue would like
you to make a mere trifle.
Honestly, it's hardly any
work at all, it's... it's trifling.
No, they've actually gotta make
a trifle.
Oh, I see. Yeah.
It's not like YOU to make a mistake.
I'm not gonna lie to you,
I've been fragile since Christmas.
I got this. OK.
The judges would like you to make
a large sharing trifle,
ideal for a soiree or a party.
Your trifle needs to have
at least three layers,
one of which has to be
biscuit or cake,
one has to be a custard
made from scratch,
the rest, put in whatever you like.
Scotch egg. Ideal.
You have two and a half hours.
On your marks. Get set. Bake.
Ah! Ahh!
OK, this is really happening.
So, we're starting with,
uh, measuring stuff, uh...
Ooh.
I thought I'd know how to do this.
I've watched the programme.
I'm like, "Well, she hasn't
whipped that butter enough.
"There'll be no air in that sponge."
Now I'm going, "What is a sponge?"
Trifle is one of those classic
British puddings, really.
At the bottom, I would put sponge.
On top of that, jelly,
on top of that, custard,
on top of that, cream.
That, for me, is the classic trifle.
I'd like to see nice,
definitive lines,
so you see through the glass
and you see all the multi-layers
that they've built up.
Ah!
The perfect texture of trifle
is quite tricky to obtain.
It should JUST hold its shape.
So when you put the spoon in,
it JUST manages to stay there.
And, of course, the other key is
a good deal of sherry or brandy
or whatever they like.
How can they mess up a trifle?
Hello. Hi, Dylan. Hello, Dylan.
Hi, there, everyone.
Let's hear about your trifle.
It's a raspberry and cherry trifle,
kind of Bakewell style
with the ground almonds.
Oh, right.
Is it ground almonds? Yes.
Have you practised this?
I have, with my mum.
Your mum did all the work
and you watched, is that right?
It was half and half.
Should your mother be here really?
Yeah. OK.
NOEL: Dylan's hoping he can recreate
his Bakewell-flavoured trifle,
finished with fresh raspberries
and a sherry-soaked almond sponge,
without the help of his mum, Jackie.
Nicola? Yeah?
Is it, is that smooth?
No. OK. Thanks.
I'm zesting one orange,
one giant... orange.
Saoirse.
Pfft!
Just get it in the oven.
That's a good thing to do.
In you go, little baby.
I have put my sponge into the oven.
That is on.
And I'm putting it
in till it's baked.
Boop, boop, ta-da!
This may be my hidden talent.
But it was hidden very, very
deep down, that's the problem.
SANDI: The trifle
Jamie-Lee is hoping
will unleash her baking potential
will combine classic flavours
in an orange curd Swiss roll,
layered with a
chocolate orange custard.
Everybody I told I was doing this,
they were like... Laughed?
"..That'll be terrible."
They're like, "Oh, my God,
"you couldn't make toast." So now
you're thinking, "I'll show you!"
Nobody entertained the fact that
I could potentially be good at this.
I've got a feeling about you.
I think you're going to do very
badly in this competition - no!
So does everybody else.
Why does everyone keep saying that?
Saoirse, happy new year.
Happy new year. Happy new year.
Can you tell me about the layers
within your trifle?
What's it start with?
Trifle.
And then custard.
Hang on a minute. Hang on a minute.
Just trifle? Trifle. Trifle, yeah.
So it's not the whole thing.
You're just putting trifle
down at the bottom.
I'm doing a Swiss roll and
a chocolate custard and a
normal custard and then that...
That makes up the trifle?
That makes up the trifle.
So you're not putting trifle down
at the bottom? Yeah, but there's
gonna be trifle throughout.
NOEL: In spite of the confusion,
there's no doubt where Saoirse
has found her inspiration.
Her trifle will be flavoured
with an Irish liqueur cream
and will be decorated
with green sugar shamrocks.
I told them what trifle was,
that was good.
Paul and Prue were a bit confused,
but I cleared that up, so,
I'm here for them.
SANDI: In keeping with tradition...
Ooh!
..to flavour their trifles, all
the bakers are hitting the bottle.
Happy new year.
Ah, takes the edge off. Ah, urgh!
Unbranded champagne,
my favourite kind.
Just gets better and better,
look at the colour of that.
Would you like to win this?
I get the feeling that you're
laidback, you're not that bothered.
Yeah, but I know Nicola's
gonna win, cos she's a pro.
Is she really good? Really good.
She's helping me a lot.
Is she? Yeah. Is that...?
Which I don't know if
it's allowed, but...
Dylan, is Nicola helping you?
I did do a little bit of help.
Of course you're helping him.
SAOIRSE: Of course
you're helping Dylan.
A little bit of mild cheating
going on here.
That's not fair.
What, he's so cute. Nicola!
Dylan!
SIOBHAN: 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
So I am making a champagne
and blackberry trifle,
in honour of my Aunt Betsy,
who doesn't drink, but she says
if she is offered a glass of
champagne, she won't say no,
which I really admire.
As well as blackberries
to flavour her whipped cream
and chocolate in her sponge,
Siobhan is using champagne
to flavour her jelly -
an element no other baker
is attempting.
Can you tell me about
this liquid you've got,
how many leaves of gelatine
have you got in there?
She doesn't know. I don't know.
There were 15 leaves in here.
And we... 15 leaves?
So we've found one.
So there's 14 in there.
Oh, that'll be...
That would set the Thames.
DYLAN: Look at that.
That looks like a cake.
Oh!
That's a good sponge.
OK, that doesn't look terrible.
SANDI: Nicola is the tent's
most experienced baker.
And she's hoping her trifle will
catch the eye of one of the judges
in particular.
It's all about Prue,
though, really, isn't it?
Is that who you want
to impress more? Yeah.
You say that. I do! But
when Paul shuffles over...
Comes over with his wolf eyes,
looking at you.
With his big, massive, sausage-y
hands, you'll be like that.
"Please like mine." Please, Paul.
"Please like my sponge."
"Please like my sausage roll."
With Prue in mind,
Nicola's making a strawberry
and rhubarb Swiss roll base,
topped with an amaretto
and mascarpone cream.
PAUL: I heard that you're
pretty good at baking
and you've been practising.
Yeah, I think I'm all right.
I mean, look at that, that's a,
it's a decent looking sponge.
That's a very decent looking sponge.
Thank you. I think you
know what you're doing,
which is great relief to me.
Good luck. Thank you.
Me and Prue are like... best pals.
Game recognises game.
Me and Prue, it's like...
CLICKS TONGUE
Yeah, she knows what it's about.
She's got it.
What are you doing?
SANDI: I-I don't know,
I don't feel right today.
You know the problem with you?
Yeah? You're off your trolley.
Oh, that's what it is. Thanks.
Bakers, you are halfway through,
halfway through!
It's rolling.
Saoirse, Nicola and Jamie-Lee
are all making a Swiss roll
for the baked layer of their trifle.
That's grand.
OK, get it sliced.
That's not great, like, is it?
The Swiss would be ashamed.
NICOLA: I realised I forgot a really
important part of the Swiss roll,
which is to roll it when it's hot.
That time has long since passed.
SHE SIGHS
OK.
OK, I'm gonna try and make this
into a Swiss roll now.
Oh, my lovely sponge.
Oh, no.
Dammit!
Eejit.
I'm actually gonna make a whole
new sponge because I'm not happy.
DYLAN: Custard.
Custard.
SANDI: Custard is a fundamental
part of any trifle.
I thought custard came in tubs!
Nothing's happening,
it's not thickening.
But when making it from scratch...
Ugh.
..patience is essential.
Why won't this bloody custard
thicken?
I've been here for months.
It might be me.
Shout at it and it might work.
Come on, custard! Thicken!
You can do it.
Come on, custard!
I think that's working.
My custard's custarding.
Look. Ah!
Let's make some custard. Whoo!
Whisking that nice custard
until it's fluffy and soft.
Everybody thought
I was gonna be crap.
Look at my custard.
Ooh, I'm so good at making custard.
Custard's in the fridge.
Do I open it? No, I won't.
No, it's fine.
Oh, what have I done?
Oh...
Um...
So, um,
I grilled it.
I don't know how, I think
I knocked it with my knee
and I have grilled the sponge,
which is an unusual move.
I don't know what to do.
Why? Um...
OK.
I'm gonna make a third sponge.
It's gonna be a record for
the amount of Swiss roll fails.
Bakers, you have half an hour,
just half an hour.
Oh! We've half an hour?!
No pleasing some people.
I don't have any
whipping cream in mine.
I've just seen whipping
cream in the fridge.
It was definitely meant
to have whipping cream.
I'm about to whip the cream
for the top of my trifle.
It should be light,
but not TOO whipped.
There are bigger words for that
but I don't know what they are.
I think I've overdone this,
but screw it.
He'll love it creamy.
I've come to help.
Oh, good.
Actually, you want a glass of
champagne? Yeah, let's do it now.
I know where to get bowls
but not glasses.
Oh, well... Let them drink
out of bowls. How French!
Slainte. That's... Slainte, slainte!
Woohoo. Ha-ha!
Ooh, that's very fizzy. Oh!
Oh, no, the cream! Oh! Oh.
Everything was going great
until you came.
I-I'm going to go get you some
more... cream. Yeah, it's grand.
Let's go back to the champagne.
It's number three, look at her.
She's gorgeous.
She's the Miss Universe of sponges.
Now, I'm not gonna forget
to roll it this time.
Oh, it's so hot.
NOEL: With all their
trifle elements complete,
the bakers can now
embark on assembly.
It's a bit squished but I
bet it tastes really nice.
It was so much better
when I made it with my mum.
I think they were a bit worried
by the amount of gelatine
I'd put in my jelly.
Dunno why they were worried.
Jelly, jelly, jelly, jelly layer.
That looks lovely.
I'll put fresh blackberries into it.
Bakers, you got five minutes left.
Five minutes? Ooh!
I don't think it's as good
as the other one.
Oh, my God. This is just lovely.
Chocolate, custard.
No time to be fancy.
It's very warm.
It's gonna melt the jelly,
oh, this is a disaster.
Sprinkle over some Maltesers.
Da-da-da-da.
Oh, yeah, I'm just
trying to do this quickly
but also very precisely,
so it looks good.
I feel like the last little
bit might be a scramble.
Ugh! I'm... I'm never
gonna finish this.
Not a hope.
I feel like I should do more
decorating, as it's quite basic.
Oh, Dylan, such a wee creep.
You're such a wee creep.
That's worryingly good.
You got one minute!
Argh!
Wow, that was quite a
big reaction there.
This is really hard, Bake Off.
It's really, really hard.
Oh, the nozzle came off.
Of course it did.
Oh, my God, this is a nightmare.
Oh! I just wanna put some gold on
and it's all sticking to my hands.
NOEL: That is it, your time is up!
Yay!
Ugh.
Place your trifles at the
end of your work stations.
Jamie-Lee, look at
Nicola's compared to ours.
Where's your... where's your...?
The Derry Girls' trifles will now
face the judgment of Paul and Prue.
Good luck, everybody.
Jamie-Lee. Paul.
Right, tell us
all about your trifle.
So my trifle is
chocolate orange surprise.
The surprise is?
Is that it turned out like
a trifle, to be honest.
You do see, certainly, three layers.
The cream probably needed
a little bit more. OK.
Let's have a look, shall we?
Oh, God.
PRUE: A bit of chocolate custard.
I think that tastes amazing.
Does it really? Yeah.
Thank you. It does.
Very good flavour.
The balance of the orange and
chocolate and the sponge is
delicious.
Your sponge is baked
beautifully as well.
If it was neater and more cream...
It would be perfect. Spot on, yeah.
Really? Oh, thank you so much.
Very well done.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
Yes! Oh, my God.
SAOIRSE: Well done!
I'm delighted.
Oh, my God, I'm so delighted.
I thought it was gonna be crap.
It is a bit messy and smeary.
Let's have a look cos, I mean,
I think it is a bit of a mess.
Wait until you try it,
you'll clean that bowl right up.
You're gonna lick it clean.
You're gonna lick her all over.
Irish liqueur all over.
CRUNCHING
Oh.
The sort of malty chocolate balls
are just lovely, when you hit them,
they explode in your mouth.
Hmm. Lovely. Thank you.
I do think it's delicious.
The Irish cream liqueur in there,
it's just the right
amount to lift it.
Your sponge is baked
beautifully as well.
And the textures are spot on.
Thank you so much. Mm!
Prue's absolutely smashing that.
Thank you.
Livid.
I'm livid.
That's the best thing to
happen to me in ages.
So, Dylan, love the way
you've decorated it.
You can see the layers, though
they're a little bit, uh, casual.
Bit wee, bit woo, yeah.
You've got height to it,
which I like, you know,
it gives you some depth
to get the spoon in there.
Wow. Wow.
It's holding its shape,
which is nice.
I hope it's not too stiff. Oo-er.
That's such a classic trifle.
Ah, good. The almond's a new
addition for me, but I like that.
Yeah, OK. Lovely.
The sponge is good
but I think you've slightly
overdid it with the custard.
It's gone slightly eggy. Yeah.
But, actually, all the
flavours and all the textures
are pretty much there.
Thank you very much. Thank you,
thanks, guys. Cheers.
You know we asked for
at least three layers?
Can't you see it?
Hmm, if you peer very hard,
you can see it.
It's all over the place.
Looks like an aquarium.
The cream on the top
actually looks quite nice.
It does. It's not overwhipped.
Well, let's see what the textures
are like, shall we?
THEY LAUGH
It does look like slime,
I have to say. Wow.
It is delicious. See,
in Ireland, we love slime.
Uh, it's traditional that we
have slime for the New Year.
Um, so please don't diss my culture.
And eat up your slime.
The flavours are lovely.
It does look revolting.
Oh, you. Some of it looks good.
You can taste the champagne. Yeah.
So you do have the taste,
and the custard tastes good
and the sponge is good.
It's just that all
the textures are wrong.
Yeah, well done.
Thank you very much. Thank you,
I think. Well done. Thank you.
Nice try. Worth a try.
I think it looks amazing.
You can see it all, sponge
looks good, jam looks good.
And you've taken real advantage of
the fact that you made Swiss roll.
If you make a Swiss roll,
you want to see that.
Yes, I made three.
That's actually the third one,
but it's... it's there.
Texturally, it's all wrong.
Need to be thicker because...
Yeah. ..it goes into a soup. Yeah.
Because you were
rushing with the sponges,
so everything else fell out
of place. Yeah, yeah.
But it's the best tasting one
in here.
It's really good.
I love the rhubarb flavour.
Yeah, the sponge is delicious
as well.
The flavours are fantastic.
Thank you. Well done, Nicola.
Thank you. Thank you, thank you.
JAMIE-LEE: Well done, everybody.
SIOBHAN: Well done, guys.
I feel pretty buzzing, to be honest.
I mean, said it was the best
tasting one in the tent.
Paul said, like,
he absolutely loved the taste.
He said it was beautiful or
fantastic or whatever.
It's the best thing he's ever had,
something like that.
But, I was not expecting that.
I'm really, really happy.
I can't wait for the Technical.
I want to go baking again.
Imagine if it was slime?
Imagine if it was Technical -
and now we have some bakery slime.
Got it, done it.
SANDI: For the first challenge, the
Derry Girls could practise as much
as they liked, but they're
going into the Technical blind.
Hello, bakers, it's time for
your Technical Challenge,
which, today, has been set
for you by the lovely Prue.
Prue, any words of advice?
Do as you're told.
Wow, I think that's just
general in life, that one.
That's more of a threat
than advice. Yeah, really.
Right, off you two pop.
What are they up to today?
Well, Prue's bought a hoverboard.
Yeah. Hence the injury. Hmm.
And Paul's gonna have a go on it.
We'll never see him again.
Right, for your
Technical Challenge,
Prue would like you to make
12 salmon and beetroot blinis.
Your tiny Russian pancakes need
to be finished with horseradish and
beetroot topping and then garnished
with hot smoked salmon and caviar.
Ah, it's the perfect
New Year's canape.
You have one hour.
On your marks. Get set. Bake!
Ah!
Ugh, another piping bag.
JAMIE-LEE: Is that caviar?
An hour?
Yeah.
This is terrifying.
I've never actually had canapes,
I don't think.
What's the point? They're too small.
Just get a full-sized thing.
Blinis then, Prue.
Why have you chosen blinis?
This is just such a nice dish
for New Year.
It's absolutely delicious.
What we're asking for is
12 identical blinis,
with really beautifully
piped cream cheese,
beetroot and horseradish,
topped with hot smoked salmon
and then some lumpfish roe, which
is my kind of caviar - affordable.
I mean, they do look good.
Have a go. Shall we tuck in? Yeah.
The blini's nice and soft.
The beetroot in it and the
cheese on the top is delicious,
got a nice zing to it, but that
hot smoked salmon and even that
little bit of dill on the top
just marries with everything.
That's a great party piece, that.
I mean, it's hard to go wrong.
You know, if they read the
recipe, they'll be fine.
It's the Derry Girls, isn't it?
Anything could happen.
OK, so, for the blinis, sift
the flour and salt into a bowl
and make a well in the centre.
Make a well.
So it seems more straightforward.
But I am really nervous,
for some reason, because
it's savoury, it feels like
it's cooking or something.
"In a separate clean bowl, whisk
the egg white to stiff peaks."
Is that the thing where you
put it over your head and
it doesn't fall out?
Are you supposed to hold
this one over your head?
No, you're not.
Are you supposed to?
Oh, no, don't. Did it?
Put it over your head.
No, it's too slidey.
I don't trust it, no. Sabotage.
I am now folding stiff egg peaks.
Folding it over again,
fold it over again.
I've never folded anything
that was liquid.
Like, I-I thought that was
impossible, but here we are.
You've got a taste for this
now, haven't ya?
I do a wee tiny bit. Yeah,
now... It's a bit sad.
..that you got a compliment
from Paul. That's all it took.
You looked into his eyes,
though, didn't you?
But it was... it's the moment... it's
the moment before, it's the...
Yeah, then his two blue eyes
come into play.
And you're like, "What's gonna
happen? And you're like...
"Is he gonna propose, or...?"Yeah.
Heat a nonstick frying pan
over a medium heat.
Spoon one tablespoon of
the batter into the pan
and cook until golden brown.
I mean, do we cook them
in the olive oil?
I feel like they're nicer,
they'd be better in butter.
But I don't look like I have any.
Cos, generally, you cook, like,
normal pancakes in butter.
SIOBHAN: Are you not using any oil?
No, cos it didn't say.
OK.
DYLAN: Jamie-Lee, did you do oil?
No.
It's a nonstick pan.
I feel weird about cooking them
in olive oil.
It'll be fine.
SANDI: I made you
an Irish biscuit.
Oh, my, wow.
Yeah. "Eejit." Yeah.
Is that Irish for "King"?
Yeah, King of Eejit.
That's you. Oh, thank you.
Bakers, you have half an hour.
Half an hour.
Urgh!
Ha-ha, eejit.
CLICKS TONGUE
Yeah?
NICOLA: So, then the topping
is beetroot, horseradish,
salt and 50g of cream cheese
and blitz until smooth.
"Horseradish cream to taste."
What does that mean?
I'm gonna guess horseradish
cos I don't like horseradish.
I like it hot, so,
I've really whacked a load
of horseradish in there.
Gonna put in a large bit, actually.
It says to taste,
and I can't taste it, so...
BLENDER WHIRS
SANDI: Oh, wow, spritzing now.
Yeah.
Is this easier or more difficult
than the trifle?
Difficult because it's all unknown.
Right. It's the unknown. Cos the
trifle you totally knew
what you were doing. You were 100%
on it. Yeah!
And then nailed the custard and
everything. Yeah, that was great.
Why did you agree to do this?
I don't know!
I'm gonna try and use up all the
mixture, just in case any go awry.
Bakers!
You have...
You were doing so well,
you finish it. I just... OK.
15 minutes.
Oh, man.
I wanna go home.
My pancakes are a disaster.
Now they're starting to
look like Yorkshire puddings.
Making extra ones because they all
have to be the same, don't they?
And I don't want any snarky comments
from certain people
about them looking different.
Spoon the mixture into a piping
bag fitted with a nozzle.
This is really hard.
Just trying not to get
the bag stuck together.
Pipe a swirl of beetroot mix
onto each blini.
I've never piped before.
Imagine if I turned out to be
a really good piper.
No.
This is really difficult.
If you go too fast,
it's gonna be a nightmare.
I'm really trying to concentrate.
I wouldn't eat these.
I'd probably eat the girls'
ones but I wouldn't eat mine.
Mine just look like
disappointing Iced Gems.
WHISPERS: Oh, Jesus.
There's half a salmon on that one.
NICOLA: I worry I'm being a
bit stingy with the salmon,
but I want them to stay
looking really dainty.
"Squeeze the lemon over the salmon
"then garnish with a small amount
of caviar and a sprig of dill."
I don't have time.
OK, I'm done with the dill.
Where was I going with the dill?
Caviar.
Dylan, stop jumping!
NOEL: Bakers, you have
one minute left.
Oh! 60 seconds... No, really?
..of caviar action.
You're... uh, like, it was... no!
WHISPERS TO HERSELF
NICOLA: Not much caviar.
Oh, my gosh.
DYLAN: It's bloody terrifying.
Just doing this really quickly.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your blinis
and place them behind your
photograph on the table.
Oh...
OK.
SIOBHAN: Oh, my God.
SHE GASPS
Ooh!
DYLAN: My God,
you guys are amazing.
Paul and Prue are looking
for 12 identical
hot salmon and beetroot blinis.
But they won't know which
blinis belong to which baker.
Looks pretty good.
However, we shall see.
We'll start with that one.
OK.
Is there 12? Yes. Yeah, it's 12.
Are they all the same?
Yeah.
I think that one's been fried
with oil, you know.
That's got oil on it. Really? Yeah.
That's delicious.
The blini's nice and soft.
Mm. It's quite airy.
Good.
Well, moving on to,
they're a bit pale, these.
They're not so well risen
and a bit hard.
Mm-hm.
Flavour's excellent.
They're a bit irregular in size,
though. Mm.
OK, moving on to number three.
They're a bit pale.
Very thin.
But they are all the same, actually.
And they're quite neatly piped.
They are good, they're soft.
You do have to open your mouth wide
and get the whole lot in together,
otherwise, you don't get a bit
of everything. Hmm.
Well, this one's very
nicely browned, isn't it?
I like the colour on that one.
Yeah.
I must say, it's lovely.
They are good,
the blini's nice and soft
and that horseradish
comes through nicely.
I mean, that is a bit
too brown, isn't it?
Yeah, that one is, but the rest
of them are all right.
Mm, and even that one tastes lovely.
Right, this one's got a tonne
of dill over it, which I like.
They're a bit inconsistent
in colour and size. Yeah.
Yes.
Mm. They're soft enough.
They really are delicious.
Huge amount on top of it, though,
isn't there? Mm. I quite like those.
SANDI: The judges will now
rank the New Year's canapes
from worst to best.
In fifth place, we have this one.
Who's this?
Dylan, they are both under-browned,
and, yet, slightly overcooked.
JAMIE-LEE: Well done.
That's a skill. That's different.
In fourth spot, we have this one.
Whose is this?
They were a little bit underdone,
a little bit inconsistent,
they needed more colour. Right. OK.
And in third place, we have this
one on the end, which is Nicola.
The blinis are just
a little bit oily.
Did you fry them in oil? Yes.
They are a little greasy to hold.
And number two is this one.
Ha, that's mine.
Ah, Saoirse. That's mine.
These are actually pretty good.
The flavour was good.
I did like the colour and they...
..but there were just a couple of
them
that were slightly inconsistent.
Well done.
Thank you.
Which means that...
THEY CHEER
Ah!
Siobhan is at the top.
The blinis were perfectly risen
and the flavouring was excellent.
So well done, Siobhan.
Ah!
JAMIE-LEE: Well done, Siobhan!
Can't believe it.
Never win anything.
Proper chuffed.
God, I've been in England too long
when I say that, "Proper chuffed."
NICOLA: Come back tomorrow,
fighting attitude.
I'm not giving up hope yet.
Now that I know how good it feels
to be first,
I'm in it to win it.
Watch out, girls.
Just one challenge remains
before Paul and Prue decide which
Derry Girl will be crowned
the first Star Baker of 2020.
Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your
Showstopper Challenge.
You excited?
TOGETHER: Yes!
Yeah, woo!
Now, as we slip
towards the year 2020,
the judges would like you to make a
cake based on your favourite decade.
Oh, I like the '60s.
I like the '60s.
Yeah, the 1860s, so impressionism
went public, the Suez Canal opened.
OK.
Your cake needs to consist
of at least two tiers,
beautifully decorated, and you
have three and a half hours.
On your marks. Get set. Bake!
OK. Ah...
OK, OK, OK, OK.
All right.
Look how quiet we all are today.
Yeah, silence. Everyone's panicked.
I think go hard or go home.
I mean, God loves a trier.
So yesterday went well.
But today's going to go even better.
I have no reason to believe
this, apart from blind faith.
I suppose I should take that out.
For the Showstopper,
we're asking the bakers for
a two-tier sponge cake,
could be more than two,
but at least one of the tiers
has to be sculptured in some way.
Now, this will appeal to the
artistic bakers in the tent,
but it's also gotta taste good.
Style and substance, please.
We want filling. We want icing.
We want decoration and, most of all,
we want flavour and
beautiful texture.
It's the chance, really, for the
bakers to show us what they can do.
I'm not holding me breath.
This could be a car crash.
NOEL: The success of a tiered cake
relies on perfectly-cooked sponge.
Mmm.
Not only must the bakers
deliver on flavour...
Yeah, that tastes good.
..they must also have
the right consistency
to be stacked and sculpted.
It said a dropping consistency,
so I feel like that's sort of,
that's a drop.
Pfft.
My cake is '60s camper van,
kind of summer love vibe,
cos I love the '60s era.
It's like the birth of cool.
SANDI: Dylan's Decade Cake
will be made up of a hill
made from Victoria sponge,
with an iconic camper van,
made from a lemon loaf,
parked on top.
I'd never done a lemon loaf
before, so we'll see how it goes.
Are you splitting it
and putting lemon curd
in the middle or anything? Yes.
PAUL: So, obviously, you're
making...
Oh, I'm not making lemon curd.
Um, I don't have time for that,
Paul. And are you making jam?
And I'm not making the jam.
What exactly are you making?
Just the sponges.
That it?
No, no, and the buttercream and
the designing. Oh, that's all right.
Who has the time to make
jam and lemon curd?
Back off, Paul.
No, I wouldn't say that to his face.
He'll knock me out.
It needs one more second.
Hello, Jamie-Lee. Hello.
Hi, how are yous?
Tell us all about your Decade Cake.
I'm gonna celebrate
when Amelia Earhart,
who was obviously the first woman
to fly across the Atlantic,
she had to make an emergency
landing in Derry.
I just think it's a really
nice part of Derry history,
that isn't political. Uh-huh. Yeah.
So gonna celebrate that and...
NOEL: Nice.
..hopefully, make a cake
shaped like an aeroplane.
I thought "That'll be easy."
SANDI: Jamie-Lee will recreate
Earhart's plane in Swiss roll
and the Derry field from vanilla
sponge with a coconut buttercream
and raspberry jam filling.
PAUL: So have you practised this at
all, no? Nope. Brilliant, um...
So, uh... I think she has
got it all in her head.
The old canoodle.
I think you're very brave.
Nearly as brave as Amelia Earhart.
Thank you very much, that's a
compliment. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Well, the oven's on anyway.
Woo!
SANDI: The bakers must resist the
temptation to open their ovens,
as this will affect the rise.
Are they ready? Are they
ready? Are they ready?
Timing is crucial.
Overbaked cake will dome and crack.
I think they can come out.
Undercooked cake may
collapse when layered.
OK, this one still is
not ready, I can tell.
Keep checking them at, like,
turns of three minutes
because I don't want to overdo them.
So I'm doing an ode to 1930s Berlin,
specifically the movie Cabaret.
NOEL: Wow. So I'm doing a very
decadent chocolate cake
with Sally Bowles' Cabaret. Oh, yes.
A bowler hat on top.
I'm in. I'm all over this.
Nicola's chocolate sponge bowler hat
will sit on chocolate sponge layers,
filled with white chocolate
and raspberry ganache,
finished with Art Deco decorations.
I think, like, for Cabaret,
I just love the music,
the design of the era.
Liza Minnelli's iconic.
I'd like to make
something, hopefully, that
looks worthy of Liza.
Oh!
Jesus.
OK, that was a disaster.
NOEL: Saoirse is the only baker
adding fruit to her sponge mix,
however, fruit must be carefully
distributed for an even bake.
Fold evenly. What is evenly?
How long is a piece of string?
I'm under pressure, really,
just to get it in the oven.
And I've lost half of it in my hair.
And everybody else has
theirs in the oven.
Saoirse's ode to the 1960s
will be made from lemon
and blueberry sponges.
The bottom layer will be finished
with a tie-dye effect fondant
and the top
sculpted into a peace sign.
PAUL: So you seem pretty
confident about this. I mean...
I seem confident about this?
Well, you know, but, uh...
With the cake mix in your hair.
PRUE: Have you ever made this
cake before in your life?
I've never made a cake before.
You've never made a cake ever?
No. Until yesterday.
And your cake was fine yesterday.
Uh. Oh, no.
I just lost loads of it.
At least I'm gonna smell good.
Good luck, thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
Ooh.
Ha-ha!
I think they're looking good.
WHISPERS: Chocolate sponge champion.
Oh, it's not good.
Is that bad? Oh.
Whoa! Jesus Christ.
The ghost of awful cakes.
Don't worry, it'll taste great, and
that's what it's all about, so...
Oh.
This has collapsed.
Oh!
It just, it just looks
like a crater now.
Hello...
Hello.
Hi.
So my decade is the 1980s.
My parents, unfortunately,
have passed away so it's, um...
..it's sort of an homage to the
holidays we had when we were small.
Of myself, my brother, my mam and
my dad and the dog,
heading camping in West Cork.
SANDI: Siobhan's making camp
on a Cork coast,
made from chocolate
and raspberry cake.
She'll then pitch her tent,
made from a local speciality.
We had this thing
that WE called Battenberg.
It was only when I moved
out of Cork did I realise that
Battenberg was
something else entirely.
So this is a Cork Battenberg.
So it's like a triangular chocolate
log, with alternate vanilla sponge
and chocolate sponge.
And that, sort of, I thought, looked
like a tent cos it was triangular.
PRUE: I mean, if it's neat and it's
beautifully done, it'll be fine,
but the main thing is...
How it tastes. ..the cake's
gotta taste good. Yeah.
Cos this is a baking show.
It... it... what?!
NOEL: Is it?
Did everyone know that? No!
I got you this. Oh, wow. What is it?
It's just hot air. Oh. It was
really hard to wrap, actually.
Oh, OK, cool. And what's this?
That's my uncle. Oh, OK. Thank you.
Bakers, you are halfway through!
Halfway.
Halfway. It's a state of mind.
Girls, is it meant to be a bit
wobbly when it comes out?
No, leave it in for a bit longer
if it is.
But I... it was in for ages.
I don't want it to be dry.
I'm just gonna flip it.
I'm taking risks.
It's split. Dammit, dammit,
dammit, dammit, dammit.
It's a broken heart!
I'm gonna try to
squeeze this back on.
I don't know what I've done wrong.
I think it's just cos
there's so much fruit in it.
So, yeah. What a pity.
It's going back in.
It's a bad way to start
New Year's, with a broken heart.
So I'm making the buttercream.
Don't try this at home. Oh!
HE GASPS
Ha, didn't get me that time.
Oh, my God, guys,
there's most of my mixture.
Argh!
NOEL: The Derry Girls are all using
fondant to decorate their cakes.
This is going to be
the sea, obviously.
I am making a tie-dye fondant
for the bottom layer
of my uncooked cake.
SANDI: I've been in this
tent for some years now,
I've never seen fondant in a mixer.
I just thought that I
would give it a go. OK.
Like a culinary experiment.
Yes.
I mean, it... that's
actually working.
If the fondant is too thick,
it'll overpower the
flavour of their cake...
I think I'm happy with this.
It's a hill. Hills are
all over the place.
..too thin and the fondant may tear.
Oh, why?
That's just getting worse.
The bottom cake this one's...
I mean, I'm guessing it's
still gonna be split in half.
Let's look.
It's still split.
I'm devastated!
Bakers, my mammy says you've
got half an hour. So it is.
Does anyone have any idea
what they just said?
That was a tough crowd.
So this is the
chocolate buttercream.
I'm doing now
the little Art Deco design.
I'm gonna spray everything I own
in life with this spray, I love it.
DYLAN: This for the grass.
Just like that summer of love,
Woodstock '60s vibe.
Do you know, this is a weird
thing about me? Cool shirts.
I was actually... I was at Woodstock.
You were? That's sick! Yeah!
I was 11. You are cool.
I wasn't that cool. I was 11,
but... No, you're cool.
That's cool? Yeah. Wow.
That is cool. I'm cool, everybody!
Dylan says I'm cool.
Well, Dylan is the king of cool.
Just put it out there.
This is Amelia Earhart.
She is fuming that
her hat's so crap.
God's sake, Amelia! Come on, love.
This camper van is
really out of proportion.
It's... the cake's too small.
I am trying to make this look like
a tent, so I'm just going by eye.
Yes! Yes!
So that's gonna be
the shape of a plane.
So this is hat number two.
This is something I wanna eat,
which is hopefully a good sign.
I am trying to get these
bits out for my peace cake
and it's about to snap at the edge.
I mean, it does taste lovely.
That looks nice, doesn't it?
Will I do it around
the sides as well?
I don't have enough.
RAPID BREATHING
I need more buttercream.
SANDI: Ready?
Yeah.
NOEL: What are you two doing?
Nothing. Nothing. Nothing at all.
This is a disaster!
What on earth's going on over there?
Nothing, just a bit of baking.
Nothing at all.
I'm going home, by the way, so...
No!
No! I wanna go home.
No, look! Look, buttercream.
Oh, my God, it's a massacre.
It's a miracle. It's a miracle.
Wheels, wheels of steel.
Oh, Dylan, that looks great.
Yeah. First wheel.
I think you might be in the lead.
Ah, no way. Yeah.
That's... I've looked around.
Oh, yeah. There's a series
of mini catastrophes out there.
It's sticking and I don't know why.
I think I'm gonna
have to start again.
This is embarrassing.
It's just embarrassing.
This is what the
English think is fun.
I'm just gonna do this.
I've washed my hands, OK,
people of Britain.
Siobhan, are you OK?
What are you on about? I'm fine.
Do you want to re-enact that
scene from Ghost with me?
I really don't want you to do that,
please, get away.
SANDI: You've got five minutes,
people.
Five minutes!
It's gonna be a sprint finish.
That's supposed to be the wing.
Urgh...
This is it.
This is the presentation board.
SAOIRSE: Ah, you can't even see
that it's tie dye any more.
Whoops.
Here, just lash it on.
I don't even know
where the cake ends.
The Sandi bus,
in honour of the legend.
Get all these little guys on.
Do as I say, Cork Battenberg,
behave and get off your wire cage.
Liberate yourself, fly free,
come on. Oh, my God.
Oh! Argh!
I've given up.
This looks like a five-year-old
made it, who had broken thumbs.
Just trying to do the peace symbol.
Still gotta do that window.
Can I ask them to look at it
in one direction only?
Uh, it actually looks like a hat.
Please don't fall apart,
please don't fall apart,
please don't fall apart.
Please don't fall apart.
SAOIRSE: Dee-dee-dee!
Bakers!
Your time is up.
EXHALES DRAMATICALLY
What you've done is remarkable.
We've never seen anything like it.
Please place your Showstoppers
at the end of your benches.
Ooh.
Well done. We are proud of you,
my children. Proud, we're proud.
Thank you.
Siobhan, you look exhausted.
I am a broken woman.
I would have a breakdown
if I had to do that again.
I couldn't do it.
I think I wrecked it. Argh!
It just didn't work out.
And I'm genuinely a wee bit annoyed.
I don't think that it
could've went any worse.
I'm just hoping that the judges
give peace a chance, you know?
I've basically ruined the memory
of my mother and father.
You think THAT'S bad, what's
Liza Minnelli going to think?
She'll be livid!
I might not go back in.
I'm gonna go home, actually.
The bakers' 3D decade cakes will
now be judged by Paul and Prue.
Jamie-Lee, please bring up
your Showstopper.
Oh, it's heavy.
The plane is sitting
quite deep into that...
Cos it crashed. Obviously.
Let's have a look, shall we?
Jamie-Lee,
the fondant is really thick.
I know.
The raspberry middle is beautiful.
It's just not the lightest
cake I've ever eaten.
It's tough as old boots.
The actual sponge is really tough.
Let's have a look at the base.
Is this the same cake, is it?
It is, but I think it's just done
better, personally.
How much rising agent
did you put in?
Did you just put baking powder in?
Yes, a little bit.
When you say a little bit...
Oh, do you know what, I got confused
with tablespoon and teaspoon.
So...
It's burning my tongue.
Is it really?
It's so nearly there, it's just...
Just too burny?
It comes down to just
weighing up carefully.
It's the hardest bit, actually,
the weighing up.
Aye. Thank you.
It is a lemon drizzle sponge
with blueberry and jam droppings.
I like the decoration, actually.
But the colours are a little
bit washed out.
Well, it's a metaphor because peace
isn't always
what you imagine it to be.
Really? Um...
Actually, it's really difficult
to do,
to not mix it up too much
and end up with grey and all.
It's so hard.
I think your cake is delicious.
I think the blueberries
and the lemon work really well.
The colour that you've managed
to achieve on the crumb
is a good indication that it's
a decent lemon drizzle cake.
The texture isn't absolutely perfect
but there's nothing ever wrong
with blueberry and lemon.
It's a lovely flavour. Well done,
Saoirse. Thank you very much.
Yes!
Is that a bowler hat? Yeah.
Not quite the right shape
for a bowler hat, is it?
It's definitely '30s looking.
I like the decoration on the side.
It's quite clever to do that.
Um, what's in that cake?
Uh, cocoa powder, margarine,
eggs, self-raising flour.
No coffee?
No!
There's an odd taste
to that chocolate cake.
And I can't identify what it is.
I don't know what it is!
It tastes quite musty.
Oh, yeah, there's muscovado
sugar in there.
How much? There's quite a lot.
Maybe it was that. Could be.
I think the top one is actually
the best one.
I think the hat is the nicest bit.
Should we have a slice of that?
Yeah, maybe!
Try and redeem myself.
Is it any better?
Sadly not!
All my hopes and dreams
are in that hat.
They're dashed!
It's an interesting flavour.
It's not necessarily chocolate,
but I do like, I do like the design.
And you have gone to a lot of effort
to create all this pattern
round the outside as well.
The base is a little
bit all over the place.
Yeah. It's not particularly neat.
It looks a bit like Plasticine,
doesn't it?
But the camper van
is quite effective.
I named it after the grooviest
chick I know - Sandi.
"The grooviest chick!"
Dylan, she's not a judge.
Why aren't you... Didn't you
name it Prue?
I should've.
Right, so the top cake is...?
That's the lemon loaf.
The camper... Yeah.
..sponge, can you see
how wet it is inside?
Oh, right. It's underbaked.
It's nearly inedible.
This one, on the other hand,
is nicely baked.
Yeah, so overall your bottom cake
is very good.
The top bit is massively underbaked.
But the flavour's OK,
strangely enough.
And the concept, brilliant.
Thank you. Well done.
Well done!
Siobhan, would you like to bring
up your Showstopper, please?
Well done.
Oh, my God, I'm sweating!
This is my rendition...
SHE STIFLES LAUGHTER
..of the happiest day of my life.
The 1980s camping holidays
with my family down in West Cork.
It looks so weird!
Oh, my God!
It may be delicious. Let's see...
He can barely eat it.
It's lovely flavour,
very chocolaty.
It's a bit dry.
Is it? Hmm.
Yeah. However, the vanilla cake
is beautifully baked.
Yeah, the raspberry jam lifts it up
with the buttercream,
so that actually is a nice
thing to eat.
Let's have a try of the
Cork Battenberg.
I just want to see
if you've got the layers.
Oh, that's beautiful.
Good.
Is that overdone as well?
The white one is
a little bit overbaked.
Oh. But your design is interesting.
Mm-hmm.
I quite like it, it's colourful.
Yeah.
It's playful. Thank you very much
indeed. Thank you.
SANDI: Well done, darling.
The chocolate sponges were
a little bit dry.
Frankly, my expectations were
so low for that cake,
I thought it was going to be
a disaster.
What I take away from this is, don't
think that you can do something
to a professional level when you've
never, ever, ever done it before.
I don't think you ever want to hear
the word musty in the Bake Off tent.
That's got to be a low point!
The crown of the Queen of Baking
is slipping slowly from my grasp.
Well, generally that went very well.
There were a few hits
and a few misses.
Now, Nicola's flavour from that
chocolate, I just couldn't identify.
Have you worked it out yet?
Uh, no. No, it's like there was
a little bit of coffee in there.
Or gravy.
Or mustard. Yeah.
So not her.
No, and I think Dylan...
Bless.
..I mean, great design.
I long for him to do better because
the flavour of the lemon cake
was absolutely perfect but the,
honestly, texture was horrible.
Oh, it was like rubber. It was cute,
though, putting Sandi on the side.
Yeah, I thought he should've won.
Well, the other one is Jamie-Lee.
I love that. I thought it was witty
and... It's clever. ..very clever.
But there was a bit of a mess up
with the rising agent.
Mm. Think she's dropped
herself out of contention, I think.
What worries me is blood
appears to be spurting out of
Amelia Earhart's neck here.
Well, she has just crashed.
I think... Saoirse did really well.
She's actually created
a nice tasting cake.
If you've never baked a cake before
and the first time you do it is
in the tent with us there,
it's just amazing.
I mean, I thought
Siobhan did OK, actually.
Her Cork Battenberg...
Cork Battenberg, yeah.
..was really beautifully done.
And the grass looked
great, as well, on that.
Yeah, the coconut worked
with it, you know?
At the moment, for me, I think
you're looking at Siobhan and
Saoirse as well.
So, they're the two people for me.
Between those two. Yeah.
I absolutely agree.
Well, I can honestly say you are
five of the most troublesome
people we have ever had in the tent,
but I can also say I don't think
we've ever had more fun.
So thank you so much for being
our first bakers in 2020
and thank you for the craic.
Aw. Thank you.
We've had a blast.
You're all winners in my eyes but
there can only be one real winner
of the Great...
..New Year Bake Off.
PRUE: Try again, Noel.
There can only be one winner
of the Great New Year Bake Off,
and the winner is...
..Saoirse.
CHEERING
Well done.
NICOLA: Can you believe it?!
Oh, thank you.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
I can't believe I won,
I'm delighted.
Thank you.
SHE SCREAMS
Oh, thank you! I'm shocked.
Saoirse won, actually, because
she was the most consistent
over the three challenges.
I think she did really
well in the Showstopper.
For someone that's
never baked before,
coming into the tent, to do what
she's done, fantastic job.
Thanks for putting up with me.
No, you were fantastic.
I was so stressed.
I've always said, if
you can read, you can bake,
and the Derry Girls
proved that today.
SHE SCREAMS
I've had the best fun,
it's been brilliant craic.
So the last thing to do
now is to have a drink
and celebrate New Year and
Saoirse's win, so happy days.
Let's go!
# Joy, joy, joy to the world
# Joy, joy, joy... #
This experience has
just been amazing.
It's been lovely to do
it with my friends.
And I'm so happy for Saoirse.
I will let her be
the queen of baking.
I can be the queen of
people's hearts instead.
Is that...?
Yeah, I can be that, it's fine.
# Let Earth receive her king... #
Happy new year!
I feel like it's kind of made us
closer baking together.
I feel like we should
bake together more.
# And heaven and nature sing
And heaven and nature sing
# And heaven and nature... #
I will take away
from this experience...
..um, a few of the bowls.
I've grown quite attached to them.
And you seem to have a lot of them.
# Joy, joy, joy... #
Could there be a better start
to 2020?
No, no, there couldn't be.
This is a pretty class one.
It's been a ball.
# Joy to the world
# Joy, joy, joy to the world. #
Happy new year!
CHEERING
Woo!
Are you a Star Baker in the making?
If you'd like to apply for
the next series of Bake Off,
visit...
Subtitles by Red Bee Media